[Music]
like an empty plastic Cola bottle
trapped in driftwood floating to the
shore john kerry's back he really is the
rare combination of a 8 year old boy I
mean he's got the maturity of an
eight-year-old boy with the insecurities
of a teenage girl
how can he move his face now he's got a
new book out and it's really a true
reflection of Kerry the books awful and
it too is made from wood but there is
some news in there apparently while the
Trump administration was busy with their
own foreign policy Kerry was busy with
his own there are people in the
intelligence community who say that
you've been telling the Iranians to wait
out the president Trump and the
administration and to wait until there's
a Democratic president in 2021 is that
accurate
well I think everybody in the world is
sitting around talking about waiting out
President Trump every Secretary of State
former Secretary of State continues to
meet with foreign leaders ghost security
security conferences goes around the
world we all do that see that's what
happens when an anchor actually reads
the book so I'm thinking holding secret
meetings with the regime that's openly
hostile to the American people seems a
little a little like what's that word
hobby backstabbing oh how about
collusion yep for two years we've
watched the media chase a phantom in an
effort to undo an election meanwhile
captain corkboard here is meeting with
the enemy giving them cryptic advice on
Trump now you might think how is this
different from working with North Korea
well Kerry is not the Secretary of State
it's not his job and it might even be
illegal to have an alternative foreign
policy going on that's separate from the
White House even more it's worse to have
it run from this guy in his basement in
his spare time and even when he was the
secretary who could forget his crowning
achievement of international diplomacy
[Music]
is cold and I will be there yourself you
got yeah yeah when Carrie had the job
that was foreign policy today that might
be an act of war or just the act of an
eight-year-old boy with the insecurities
of a teenage girl but taller all right
we got a lot of smart people here let's
go around the table against the law
Logan Act should he go to should is this
treason Jesse lock him up
that [ __ ] was for him not Hillary I
think Carrie owes an apology to teenage
girls because when I was in high school
I was much more insecure than the girls
that I was in the class with I honestly
think this is all about just giving CPR
to his legacy because when you think
about his whole trajectory he'd served
honorably in Vietnam and then he kind of
tarnished that service when he came back
and disparaged his fellow soldiers then
he lost in a kind of a humiliating
fashion to george w bush now a nuclear
deal as Secretary of State's kind of
like the crown jewel for these people
especially Democrats so Trump comes in
just rips up the piece of paper and
carries left saying well what do I have
left so he's desperate to salvage this
thing and could you imagine if Mike
Pompeo in seven and a half years or
maybe longer
Kozak tries to undermine the current
Democratic presidential administration
he would get hammered by the media I
mean you don't see Bill Clinton going
down to Mexico City and trying to save
NAFTA after Trump rips that up it's
unseemly and he should be called out for
it well he does go to Mexico City but
not for that what Kerry met with went in
Paris with enemy and boys what in 1970
he met with Daniel Ortega while Reagan
was president that was outrageous this
guy is a traitor traitor I say he's got
a Greg Rock hearing here I'm hearing
Swift boating
after that we're back to that what I
agree with you about is that the
interview did a good job but I will say
that I recommended questions right they
wanted me to ask about John T you're
gonna say John Tesh there's a big
difference to be made a distinction to
be made between negotiating and I don't
think he's negotiating and talking and
saying which I think everybody says
who's not a Trump band look take it easy
don't overreact don't get angry don't
think that somehow this is an invitation
than out for you to go after Israel or
do something else or to relaunch your
nuclear program take it easy let's talk
about that I don't think there's
anything criminal about that he's
undermining this administration by the
way there was a great interview and you
got him to admit yeah okay yeah I'm sort
of doing this but isn't everybody doing
this I mean he hates this president so
much as so many on the Left do that they
think that they're totally fine
basically - well to use your word commit
treason they think it's okay they're
justified because they think there's
some bigger greater purpose that they're
serving the American people didn't know
what they were doing when they elected
Donald Trump he's rationalizing to
himself I need to save the country I
need to say of the people I mean you can
go back to the anonymous article in The
New York Times right the anonymous op-ed
where there's the sense that there's
this greater good that they're somehow
performing and carries part of theirs if
if you believe it that it's evil then
everything's acceptable
Dana drew everybody got upset about when
during the trim transition Donald Trump
made some phone calls everybody was like
oh my god she made the first phone call
to Taiwan yes I will the Chinese are
gonna get so mad and then like a lot of
the neo-cons like this is awesome we
love that I also remember when Nancy
Pelosi during the Bush administration of
Bush 43 s administration went to Syria
to meet with Assad hmm that's right if a
photo op and everything mine so treason
is in the eye of the beholder she
thought she was
going and being very helpful heavy
meanwhile the Bush administration is
having an actual sanctions talk at the
UN so there is a problem you have to
wait it's also what Mike Flynn is
accused of doing when he called
ambassador kis lyac and he talked about
sanctions which was against Obama
administration policy what yeah couldn't
you have waited yeah maybe but not that
big a deal because it's like two weeks
later his problem is that then he lied
about it
you okay can I ask you a question did
you read it you read his book didn't you
I read most of it it is 600 pages in
that same weekend I had to read
Woodward's book so I sort of felt like I
was studying for finals I'd like to make
an announcement I am now a member of
Danny's book club she invited right but
that's right
what's the what if what's the first
assignment is it a hearty book I haven't
finished it sir I don't I read a novel
this weekend of course you did I'm gonna
make my point I saw a movie I saw Mandy
the new Nicolas Cage movie it's amazing
it's like being trapped in a heavy metal
song with demons that sounds it's
fantastic no it's great I had a better
time
I went to see Paul Simon I was like the
youngest person there ZZ Top and Paul
Simon yeah one you're getting a ride you
do Trish oh I had an amazing amazing
weekend I'm actually gonna talk about it
later
Oh